the question that we really wanted to
answer with this project was you know
the same types of vaccines and places
the western developed economies which
are highly vaccinated are we seeing a
different impact in these places or is
the effect of the vaccines really the
same and so what we did was to take the
places that had vaccination coverage of
over 55
um and bigger places for populations
over 1 million and then we further
narrowed this to a group of places that
have seen a wave of cases pre and
post-vaccination in some places
vaccinations seem to be able to bring
deaths down to a much bigger level and
the question really was why and what can
the world learn from that
so of course there are many factors that
affect fatalities the analysis is really
only looking at the impact of
vaccination there's so many other things
that do come into play of course but
some of the big takeaways that we could
see in that contrast between places that
really managed to get dust really down
after vaccination was the length of the
interval between the first and second
vaccine dose did seem to play an
important role so for the european
countries that managed to bring
fatalities down to just 10 of what they
were at the previous peak you know we
saw uh in places like denmark and the uk
and germany for example they were
administering vaccine doses six weeks
apart in the uk that was up to eight to
twelve weeks apart whereas um in places
that have brought thefts down to a
smaller level the us japan israel they
were administering vaccine doses only
three to four weeks apart we've seen
that those longer intervals actually do
boost the immunity level much higher
we've seen this now from studies the
second dose is more powerful when the
first dose has been given that time to
fully mature in the body and that could
play an important role and there's a lot
of lessons there for countries that are
now still ongoing their vaccination
campaign and so what happened to those
earliest vaccinating countries by the
time delta came through and started
spreading across the world those initial
doses we do see the immunity has already
weighed and that could have played a
part in the fact that vaccination did
not provide as strong of a shield
towards delta compared to other
countries
so i mean the global vaccination
campaign is still ongoing there are so
many countries especially in the
developing world that haven't that don't
have any meaningful vaccination
protection at all and with the virus
becoming endemic we do know that
vaccinations may become a regular thing
what this analysis can tell us you know
is to give scientists policymakers an
inkling of some of the things that can
be done to strengthen that shield of
immunity against new variants because as
we know there is a great fear that delta
is not the only new mutation that's
going to come the world could be served
by another new variant and with the
vaccination strategy things like longer
dosage intervals waning immunity that
could influence how countries now
continue with their vaccination progress
and how they can get that shield of
immunity even stronger
[Music]